The brain is amazing and complex and this has led to a lack of understanding of a large variety
Of legends over the years.
Such as "The Great is the Best". While this may be true for some other members, you just need
Look at the brain whales Amber, the largest 6 times of the human brain, to see
This myth collapses. Yes, they are certainly intelligent animals, but their cognitive skills
Dwindling compared to what we have
It was an enjoyable night? Do not worry, alcohol actually does not kill brain cells. although
It causes damage and creates problems in transmitting messages between neurons, damage
Are mostly reversible. Similarly, medications do not actually create holes in the brain.
Although some can permanently alter the functions of the brain, its structure,
The only thing that can put a hole in the brain is physical trauma.
A good thing is that you have 100 billion brain cells - or not. Surprisingly, it was not until 2009
That scientists have discovered that the real number to be closer to 86 billion. Make sure it looks
Is a small difference, but these 14 billion neurons are equal to the size of the monkey's brain.
To further develop these figures in perspective, see that 1 million seconds
Is 12 days, while 1 billion seconds is 31 years old. The difference is 14 billion neurons
It may not be too small after all.
Regardless, we can not use all of them, right?
Most movies and science fiction books carry us to believe that humans can only use about 10% of our brain ... which is nonsense.
With modern brain scanning technology, we know we are using the whole thing - all the time!
Not necessarily every time - when you walk, for example, parts of the brain
Associated with a more active movement than other areas. However, there is no part of
The brain simply does not do anything. It represents 3% of body weight and uses 20% of your body's energy needs.
This is a busy brain!
But we generally use one side more than the other, do not we? Both! At the time it may be
I am convinced that if you are more logical or analytical, you are more using the "left brain" and if you are more
Creative or intuitive that you are using the "right brain" it simply is not true. While different aspects
Of the brain is already used to perform specific functions - for example, language is used
Language is used in the left half of the brain while the right half helps to read emotions
- Studies on thousands of individuals have not found evidence of right or left dominance in individuals.
In other words, you can use both sides.
And you do not actually have 5 senses as I always said - in fact, you have
Much more! For example a sense of pain, or body posture, in the sense of how our bodies are centered.
Not to mention the sense of balance, temperature
And the passage of time.
Scientists at Global Research Centers GE is collaborating with leading researchers
And institutions to reveal new insights about brain functions. If you are interested
In uncovering falsehoods or understanding more about the brain, you can follow its progress
In the GE reports, they work together to eliminate the greatest brain superstitions.